hoy al clima no ha sido tan malo como
ayer pero como ven llueve a esta hora en
cres y este condiciones climáticas
ayudan a que los enfrentamientos no sean
tan intensos como cuando el cielo está
cubierto especialmente porque los drones
no pueden operar de la misma manera y
terminan siendo los ojos no solamente de
la artillería sino también de la
Infantería esto En un momento en que la
situación en muchos frentes en el donbas
especialmente en bakmut siguen siendo
inciertos y también a nivel militar el
el gobierno del presidente se lensky la
presidencia ha publicado un decreto en
el que cesan a quien fuera el jefe
militar de esta zona del donbas Sin dar
mayores motivos aquí tampoco hay muchas
especulaciones pero la realidad es que
la situación no es fácil tanto para los
rusos pero tampoco para los ucranianos
hoy no hemos tenido mayores noticias de
bakú pero sí sabemos que aunque siguen
teniendo el control de algunas partes
del centro algunas unidades o batallones
estarían retirando solamente hay una vía
de acceso
como hablábamos ayer y las gran pregunta
es si llegaran a retirarse para
reagruparse y luego volver a atacar Como
lo hicieron por ejemplo en la zona de
Hacia dónde lo harían hemos visto por
ejemplo la zona de Constantinopla que
está bastante cerca a vacuna ahí estaba
toda la presencia militar de la zona lo
hemos visto mucho más vacía que lo
veíamos hace un mes por ejemplo sin
saber muy bien hemos visto también
algunas líneas de coches militares salir
pero también otras entrar y esta
situación se repite también en otros
frentes como el de cremita es batove
donde los enfrentamientos continúan
abdica Así que la situación en el don
vas en este momento es bastante crítica
esto es un momento también de cambio de
clima como decíamos están quietos en el
día de hoy a la espera de saber qué va a
pasar en las próximas semanas y meses
donde también se habla de una próxima
ofensiva ucraniana pero esta vez para
detener las líneas que cortan ese
corredor entre el donbas y la isla de
crimea Pero esto todos son
especulaciones y posibilidades